want to know what are the best ways to
start a chess game I'm here to help
try starting by moving this Pawn in
front of your king forward two squares
now both your bishop and queen can get
out
if your opponent is also just learning
how to start a game they will probably
do the same thing
now you can develop your knight forward
to this Square attacking their Pawn
if they defend that pawn with their
Knight it's time to get your Bishop out
try this square right here attacking
their Pawn
congratulations you've successfully
played the opening chess players call
the Italian game
if your opponent now plays their night
here you can actually gang up on this
week's square with both your knight and
Bishop
otherwise they might play their Bishop
out here
you're now free to get castled and then
you can develop the rest of your pieces
on your upcoming terms
hope you enjoyed these tips and enjoy
your new opening